wo ist dein weg
[Musik]
also welche migrations gründe kennt ihr
die menschen verlassen ihr land weil sie
in ihrem eigenen land keine perspektive
müsse stimmt aber woran kann das liegen
sie sind unzufrieden mit ihrer regierung
politische gründe
manche werden sogar verfolgt diese
menschen könnte in anderen ländern asyl
beantragen
wer kann ganz alles menschen die in
kriegsgebieten leben oder menschen die
extrem arm sind ja im grunde genommen
alle menschen die um ihr leben fürchten
müssen
sie hoffen auf ein bisschen frieden in
einem anderen land aber das ist oft
nicht so einfach was gibt es für
probleme
bürokratie ja aber das größte problem
ist wahrscheinlich dass man die sprache
nicht kann und dann folgt der ganze
papierkram asyl beantragen visum
beantragen pass beantragen ausweis
beantragen
und das sind nur ein paar beispiele ihr
habt alle einen migrationshintergrund
und trotz der ganzen schwierigkeiten
setzen wir alle hier zusammen und lernen
zusammen warum alle zusammen lernen
wollen probleme zu lösen
weil wir wie es denn da sie davon uns
irgendwann mal hilfe braucht
ein zuhause zu finden indem man sich
auch zu hause fühlt jetzt nicht einfach
aber jeder verdient das findet ihr nicht